what's going on guys this is rob and i
apologize for the crappy audio and video
and everything here um i didn't want to
drive half an hour back to the office
just to record this video but i have to
make a video on this because this is
going to blow your mind so everybody's
talking about it now um but when we
edited the video for the spider-man
trailer 2 reaction or breakdown
whichever one it was my editor alex sent
me an image a couple images of electro
and his thought was elektra was using an
arc reactor
from tony stark right using like stark
tech on himself
now here's the thing
this is entirely possible
it's 100 possible i know some people
aren't going to be a huge fan of it
because they're like oh my god really
like tony stark is like this whole thing
sticking around yes right it's entirely
possible now the question has to be
asked if electro is using stark tech how
did he get his hands on it so fast but
this is one of the things that we're
missing here
the passage of time so let's talk about
this for a second let's assume that what
we see in the trailer like what we see
is what we get that there's no hidden
meanings there's no skipped scenes or
anything like that and the dialogue is
basically on its face exactly what it
looks like right so let's take for
example the whole thing of like the
spell right that peter parker really is
the reason why the spell gets screwed
out because he won't shut the hell up so
the spell goes awry that leads into the
statement doctor strange makes in the
trailer which is when you botch the
spell right so obviously dr strange sees
peter parker at fault for the spell
being screwed up now in this trailer god
this is nuts in this trailer he also
says uh go scooby do this right like
basically go deal with this now by and
large we see a few scenes with doctor
strange but we don't see him in any of
the fight scenes and that makes perfect
sense one of the things we talked about
in the episode of the roundup is that if
this portal over over new york city is
opening and it's leading to spider-man
villains showing up presumably other
people that we haven't seen yet then it
seems kind of silly to believe it's a
localized thing that is only happening
there especially when you consider the
fact that venom was yanked into the mcu
in a post-credit scene which means now
we know it's affecting san francisco you
move beyond san francisco you follow the
most logical course this is happening in
different places around the world i
would even argue not only is it
happening in the world it's happening
across the universe right like portals
are opening across the universe because
all these different universes across the
multiverse are basically slamming into
each other right they're literally just
hitting each other they're crossing over
like they're not supposed to now i still
stick by the idea this is all because of
loki but let's just ride this assumption
that it's all because the spell would
arrive because of peter parker here's
the question i would have
does it sound reasonable that doctor
strange would ignore all of that
to help spider-man catch
five guys and not just five guys five
guys who aren't really even worth the
attention of doctor strange i mean let's
be honest the sorcerer supreme right the
guy who has in some capacity explored
the multiverse i have a hard time
believing he's gonna set all that aside
to find a guy with four tentacles on his
back a dude made of sand a giant lizard
a guy who can control electricity a
crazy dude on a goblin glider that's not
gonna happen all right it's just it's
it's not going to happen so that makes
sense why doctor strange would say go
scooby do this right like you made this
mess you fix it i'm the sorcerer supreme
this is happening on a much larger scale
than just new york i've got more
important things to worry about that
explains why we don't really see doctor
strange around there all that often but
here's the bigger thing from that right
here's why that is important if that's
true that buys us time because there's
no way tom holland spiderman would be
able to capture dr octopus and electro
and sandman and the lizard and the green
goblin in one night that's never going
to happen there's no conceivable way
that could happen he doesn't have the
skill set to do it yet he doesn't even
know who these guys are he doesn't know
their strengths their weaknesses he
doesn't know what they're capable of
he'll figure it out as time goes on and
i'm sure the intervention of toby
maguire and andrew garfield will help
with that but because it's all not going
to happen in one night this is probably
going to happen over a series of days if
not maybe a few weeks or so that buys us
time that would explain how electro
could get his hands on an arc reactor
that belonged to tony stark not only
that one of the things to keep in mind
if my memory serves me and i could be
entirely wrong here the original arc
reactor of tony stark was just sitting
in the water or put in the water and
just kind of floating down a river or
whatever it is right i imagine any
number of people could pick that up but
assuming that's not the case one of the
things to contend with is what we
brought up in the rumor roundup which is
the vulture played by michael keaton
looking at the morbius trailer in that
little scene where like michael keaton's
like hey we should catch up sometime it
looks like they're letting him out maybe
he's being transferred it's kind of hard
to tell but it looks like his term is
done he's out right he's a free man and
so in that instance while i wouldn't go
as far as to say that vulture would be
an instrumental figure in like the
sinister six type team that we're gonna
see an amazing spider-man we do know
from just the history of his character
in spider-man homecoming he's the guy
that knows how to get a hold of things
that people have a hard time getting a
hold of he used to work for damage
control remember they're the guys that
clean up after superhero conflicts and
so the guys still probably got to have
contacts or still knows how to get in
contact with people whatever it is it
wouldn't surprise me if vulture had arc
reactor technology at his disposal maybe
it's not active maybe he doesn't know
how to use it but electro could now why
does that matter because an amazing
spider-man vol 1 issue number nine back
when he first appeared in marvel comics
and some of the subsequent stories
afterwards you learned that yes electro
has the ability to control electricity
but it's finite for him right he doesn't
have an infinite amount of electricity
in his body that he can use and so what
he actually did was he used a
combination of star tech and other
technologies to basically build and
enhance this recharging device on the
front of him that would basically allow
him to quite literally recharge his own
body so he could use his powers
indefinitely and so because of that it'd
be very very easy to take that concept
and roll it over into electro why
because the arc reactors are
self-contained technology right like
iron man powered his suit using arc
reactor technology it's not like an
apple watch where he just plugs the arc
reactor into a usbc port leaves it
overnight and then plugs it in the next
morning it's designed to recharge itself
right it's a total self-contained source
of energy and so if electro gets his
hands on that then that would basically
explain why it is he looks like he has
this kind of start tech on it now that
would also explain why he looks
different because if what you have is
elektro in the andrew garfield spiderman
movies where he's basically just
immersed in electrical energy if you
look at that movie for what it is he's
basically a brand new villain he doesn't
understand exactly how his powers work
he doesn't understand exactly how to use
his powers there really isn't much about
what he can do that he fully grasps and
so at the same time if that's the case
it'd be very easy to say he doesn't have
a way to kind of contain his powers but
then you throw him into the mcu right so
like he crosses over when all the
different villains start showing up he
looks exactly like he did in the events
of of amazing spider-man with andrew
garfield but then once he gets his hands
on stark technology that allows him to
basically channel his power directly
into that arc reactor and then just use
his power as he needs it which takes
away the physical appearance of him
looking just irradiated with all this
electrical energy i mean sure it's cool
but the electrical energy is no longer
flowing through his body in that way
instead the electrical energy he has is
channeled into this device do you guys
remember when iron man got that
injection from black widow and iron man
2 when they were randy's donuts and like
the stuff on his neck began to recede
and go away that because again that
electrical energy isn't really in his
body anymore it is but it's funneled
from his body directly into that reactor
which shows why all that energy is
contained there what that also does is
it makes it very easy to defeat him
because if you take that away then there
goes all that energy he has stored up
all he has is what's ever left in his
body and then you in turn throw him into
a river or something like that i have no
idea but that makes sense guys and even
if we're not 100 right i have to believe
there's at least some aspect of this
that has to be right i mean does it does
not me i mean like let me know in the
comments does this make sense does it
sound like it's possible you guys see
now why i had to just record this video
here right i'm shooting on a sony zv1
right with just like this built-in
microphone it's the crappiest system for
like a professional youtuber to use but
i just i had to record it
i had to fire this vlogging camera up
and record this thing let me know what
you guys think in the comment section do
you think it's possible do you think it
sounds a little too far-fetched
because i think it works i think it
really
really works i think it's entirely
possible here especially if we go with
the idea that some measure of time is
passing between the time that peter
parker meets dr octopus and in the time
that he meets green goblin he fights
them maybe like one each day or one
every couple days or something like that
but it stages it and so it allows the
villains by virtue of their existence
here and then learning about the
different villains that are out there
and how they can best utilize their
knowledge and expertise to overcome
spider-man how to basically allow that
to happen because maybe he doesn't fight
electro until like day 10. so elektro's
been here for like two business weeks
before peter parker actually finally
finds him and fights him because i have
to believe that there's probably going
to be some major conflict when they
first arrive but then like they'll
scatter right they'll basically scatter
all over the place maybe that's
literally what doctor strange said go
scooby do this right go find these guys
so obviously they're not all centrally
located they're not all hanging out at
the ihop and peter parker just come
busting in you know and like in the
middle of them eating pancakes like
attacks them all i mean they're just
scattered all over the place so peter
parker's got to find him let me know
what you guys think if you think this
works or not but thank you guys for
watching for real if you're true i
promise this is the last video this is
this thanksgiving week i'm gonna give my
guys a week off but i had to record this
let me know what you guys think thank
you for watching i'll catch you guys
later peace